il y en a beaucoup qui me connaissent
pas encore il ne s'en cache pas et ben
je me présente Christopher Bellinger ce
n'est pas un candidat vedette mais c'est
sur lui que le Parti libéral du Québec
mise pour conserver son château fort
dans saint Henri Sainte-Anne après la
démission de Dominique Anglet
c'était présenté aux dernières élections
dans la circonscription voisine il est
arrivé deuxième derrière la Solidaire
Manon Massé il faut bâtir sur nos forces
puis il faut aller l'avant et je pense
qu'on m'a qu'on m'a mis ici parce qu'on
sait très bien que j'ai une attache
émotionnelle au quartier c'est important
d'avoir une attaché émotionnelle
un quartier diversifié du Sud-Ouest de
Montréal ici près de 37% de la
population par une autre langue que le
français à la maison tu speak
frenchy alors on va travailler très très
fort
à votre la loi 9
5 en véritable adversaire dans cette
partie Québec qui ont un discours qui
veut se rapprocher là donc de nos
communautés pour la défense des droits
et libertés mais qui dans les faits vote
pour le 96 alors c'est ça que solidaire
ce sont des contradictions nous on
passera pas notre campagne à répondre
aux attaques du Parti libéral arriver
deuxième le 3 octobre dernier avec 27%
des suffrages l'avocat en immigration
Guillaume klechrivard tenta nouveau sa
chance avec les solidaires tout ce qui
brille les droits et libertés dans la 87
dans la loi 96 la classe sur le Sigma
des immigrants pour apprendre le
français ça ne tiendra pas la route sous
un gouvernement solidaire c'est certain
au-delà de la protection du français
l'enjeu du logement préoccupe les
électeurs comme Diane Guindon
c'est les logements sont difficiles à
avoir sans trop cher c'est Victor
Pelletier 21 ans président de l'aile
jeunesse de laka qui va représenter le
parti lors du scrutin le 13 mars
prochain le Parti québécois n'a toujours
pas présenté de candidat ni le parti de
conservateur du Québec mais on s'est
déjà que ça ne sera pas le chef irréguet
ici jacauderie Charbonneau Radio-Canada
Montréal